okay so jurassic world no way home is
finally here and the brand new movie
brings together the older new cast so
that they can take down the dinosaurs
from the days of future past this new
film is basically about how life uh
finds a way and throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down the plot
ending and also what we think of the
film you bet jurassic will be full of
bad puns and this video will have major
spoilers in it so if you don't want it
ruined then i suggest you extinct the
video make sure you hit the thumbs up
button if you enjoy it and also don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every week without the way yeah
thanks for clicking this now let's get
into jurassic world dominion so the
movie is set four years after the events
have fallen kingdom and primarily it
follows owen claire and maisie who now
live out in the wilderness attempting to
hide the latter away from the world last
movie we learned that maisy was a clone
of her mother charlotte and throughout
this film we unearth exactly why she's
so special we discover that maisy was an
immaculate conception and that her
mother carried her in her own womb which
is something that was hidden from maisie
by her grandfather turned out that she
was genetically bred to be exactly the
same however charlotte discovered that
she had a reginated condition within her
that would prove to be fatal she managed
to remove this from maisie so that she
no longer carried this disease but she
took the secret of how to accomplish
this with her to the grave we discover
that doctor wu has been seeking her out
so that he can find a way to eradicate
the genetically modified locust that
he's been creating for the company
biosin now biosin is basically an
opposite to injen and it's headed up by
lewis dodgson who you might remember as
being a character from the first
jurassic park movie he's the only actor
not to return because the guy who
originally played him is now a convicted
sex offender so instead they've got in
the amazing spider-man's dad also bio
sin like biological sin in case in case
you were wondering who the bad guys were
now he's headed up the locust project
and it's theorized by ellie that these
swarms have been attacking crops
throughout the world that aren't made
through seeds that have come from the
company they're on their way to causing
a food crisis that will lead to billions
of people starving and there she goes to
get help from dr alan grant
[Music]
this takes them to bio sin which is
where uh dr ian malcolm works at and on
the opposite side of this we follow owen
and claire as they attempt to rescue
maisie along the way they come across
kayla and the movie basically revolves
around them taking out biosin and
surviving all the dinos there that
inhabit the location i don't know what
to tell you but it's very member berries
and as the group get back together we
have several easter eggs from the series
popping up ellie ends up looking over
triceratops like she did in the first
film flares are used to make dinosaurs
go in a certain direction malcolm brings
up how many kids he has a dilophosaurus
pops up alan asks about a t-rex on a
helicopter and before you can say i'm
blue dabba d dabba dai we're getting
characters sat next to people that look
like dennis nedry also i'm not sure
whether bryce dallas howard was pregnant
during this movie or not but they have a
large number of scenes where she's
standing with a coat covering her belly
legit have a moment early on where she
says she's just out burning a coat and
yeah you should have just make her
pregnant yeah just make her pregnant in
the movie make owen the dad now ellie
allen and malcolm end up rescuing maisie
and they attempt to escape which is when
they come across owen claire and kayla
out in the forest however they've got
bigger bigger bigger issues that pop up
when a giganotorus shows up in the
forest it's a giganotourist it's it got
gigan giganoto look either way it took
me back to the days of dino crisis 2
when that massive monster used to chase
you towards the end of the game and i
always thought it was pronounced
gigantosaurus but i guess not now this
creature is the largest predator to ever
walk the earth and it becomes the main
dinosaur antagonist towards the end of
the movie now the group attempt to climb
a tower as the giganotosaurus tries to
eat them and it's during this that ian
malcolm lights a branch on fire however
unlike the fly in the first movie he
ends up throwing it in the beast's mouth
at the top of the tower claire stuns it
and it then flees while stallis has been
going on dodgson has tried to incinerate
the locus so that the truth of biosync
can't be discovered but they end up
escaping and they cause a forest fire as
the compound burns his right hand man
ramsay goes to see him which is where we
see the shaving cream can from the first
movie this was recovered in camp
cretaceous but ramsay doesn't want to
let it go to the archive 81 and it's
revealed he said dodgson up the group
realized that in order to escape they
need to restore the power and whilst one
group handles that the others go after
blue's baby forgot to mention that that
was also stolen by biosyn along with
maisie and that's why these breakdowns
are terrible i'll not lie to you now the
powering up scene is done in a very
similar way to the one from the first
movie and you have to hand it to ellie
she's good at turning on switches and
turning on alan grant
now dodgson attempts to flee with her
precious precious scientific research
and he's killed by three dilophosauruses
these spit acid in his face mirroring
the fate that nedry had whilst he was
working for him guess he couldn't dodge
sudden
now as the group attempt to escape they
come across doctor wu and though the
last two have seen him as somewhat of a
villain he helps to engineer a way to
stop the locust thus saving the planet
as they try to get to kayla's chopper
the tyrannosaurus shows up and then the
giganotosaurus this is the big battle
that the whole movie's been building
towards and no one is initially t-rexed
she gets the upper hand after a little
help from a friend rexy pushes the
giganotosaurus into the claws of a thera
theranitosaurus which impales it on its
sharp talons as for xy this is supposed
to be the same one that popped up all
the way at the start of the first movie
and
you know they're basically best mates
with the humans now now in the end allen
and ally case after he says he's coming
with her throughout the movie she said
she thought he wanted to be alone but
being back with her has made him realize
how happy he is this is murad and maisie
2 who ends up seeing the family that she
was fighting against for what they truly
are doctor wu ends up engineering the
locus dna in order to save the planet
and he attributes this to charlotte
rather than taking the credit himself
one of these is unleashed and rather
than destroying the crops the creatures
now fly away ramsay ends up becoming a
whistleblower on biosin and though
humanity was struggling to live with the
dinosaurs we decide to make peace with
them at biosin valley the dinosaurs
there are granted sanctuary
and they're allowed to live free away
from the outside world there are several
t-rexes here which also mirrors the end
of the lost world now there is the
potential that ramsay could in fact end
up taking the dinosaurs in a positive
direction whereas they've been exploited
in the past he could end up caring for
them being a whistleblower shows where
his allegiances lie and with biosin
valley now being a sanctuary he could
look after them baby blue is also
reunited with her mother you're my boy
blue
you're my boy no you're my girl blue and
they run off into the forest together
this not only mirrors the ending of
fallen kingdom but it also shows that we
must learn to live with the dinosaurs
life er finds a way and in the end
they've been here longer than we have
the humans managed to bring the
dinosaurs into earth's ecosystem and the
movie ends with a hopeful message
whereas it was thought that one species
would push the other two extinction we
see that these animals manage to
co-exist alongside the others on the
planet we must coexist too if we both
want to survive and it ends the film on
a positive note going forward there are
rumblings of a sequel and there
certainly are a number of characters
that they could go with such as maisie
ramsay or kayla we could also get a
prequel as we discover in charlotte's
video diaries the engine had developed
dinosaurs back in the 1980s however this
very much feels like a closing of the
book to me and it wraps up both the park
and world trilogies personally i think
they should probably give it a rest for
a bit and i'm guessing that if the
series does come back they'll just add a
new word onto the end of jurassic like
jurassic park in space
now as for my thoughts on the movie i
think the series is probably gonna go
extinct after this one as it's pretty
underwhelming and isn't being well
received the money it makes will either
make or break it but i don't know how
it's gonna be taken by general audiences
i don't think it's as bad as the reviews
i'm making it out to be but there are a
number of weird choices in it that make
it the worst film in the franchise in my
opinion three might be there as well
falling kingdom's not that good either
but either way the locust plot is a
weird driving force as is the human
cloning one the both of which i think
bogged down this film jurassic park
movies are supposed to be about the
dinosaurs and in the same way that the
godzilla franchise ends up worse off
because of the human drama i think this
does too there's a vast number of scenes
that are pretty meh and the more we've
moved away from the park the worse i
think the series has got i think these
films are at their best when they're in
one location like pork lost world 3 and
world and i'm not sure it works as a
globetrotting adventure and there are
some high points in it like the
phenomenal parachute scene the raptor
chase and also the dinosaurs that pop up
towards the end however they aren't
impactful enough in my opinion and when
comparing them to the rest of the
franchise i feel they fall short this is
a series that had the t-rex scene the
raptors in the kitchen the 2t rexus is
the caravan dangled over the cliff the
spinosaurus that woman getting eaten in
jurassic world for being on her phone
too much and the brachiosaurus in the
fire from fallen kingdom i just don't
think that this movie has scenes that
stick in my memory like that and it
feels very much like a clone of the
previous films but it doesn't live up to
them this metaphor can be applied to the
entire franchise and in a way the
jurassic park series is a lot like
jurassic park itself you had the oren
wonder the first time you saw it but
then there were a couple of disasters
they then rebooted the park but after a
number of deaths they just kept going
even though anyone else would have been
like mate people have died stop trying
to make this park a thing now bi people
have died i mean the movies have been
meh but much like biosin there's too
much money involved in letting the
dinosaurs just go extinct there's been
so many false starts and things going
wrong with jurassic park that i think
they should just scrap the whole thing
the park and the franchise it's a bit of
a long-winded way to say that this movie
didn't really need to be made and that
they were so occupied with seeing if
they could do it they didn't stop to
think whether they should i'm sure
you'll enjoy it though if you turn your
brain off and the nostalgia of seeing
the original cast back definitely does a
lot of the heavy lifting the moments
with allen ellie and ian are by far the
strongest parts of the film at least we
get some closure on what happened to
them for the rest of the series though
i'm happy for this to be as dead as the
dodo and that's why it gets a 5.5 out of
10. obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie i know there's
people who think it's worse than what
i've said and some who think it's better
so comment below and let me know we are
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the batman
on the 15th of june and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the movie we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now say that to
you then message me on twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want to email us to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown at the boys which will be
linked on screen right now we've gone
over the latest episode had a lot of fun
with it so definitely head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see you next time take care
peace